Cô quan lý và sê dựng công trình thuy lời, bộ nông nghiệp và phát triển nông thương, trong thẳng tám, nhiều hô vực chiến cả nước có khả năng sức hiện lũ, đặc biệt tại Bắc Bộ, Trung mộ và đậm bằng xong cử lắm.
Tại Bắc Bộ, dự kiến có một đến thái đật lũ, đình lũ phủ biến ở mức báo động một đến báo động 2, một số xong dùi nhỏ có thể vượt báo động 3.
Bác Trung mộ và Trung Trung mộ có thể ghi nhận các đật lũ với mực nước trên xong đặt báo động một đến báo động 2,
trong trình dự nơi thấp hơn Trung mình nhiều năm.
Cô vực tên viên và năm Trung bộ có su rữ phần ngoà mạnh,
viết cơ thế uống sống trẻ tại nhiều xong suổi chiến.
Đăng chú ý, tại đồng bằng xong cử lắm,
một nước lũ đồng vùng xong cử lắm có su rữ tăng mạnh,
có thể anh vượt đến gần 2,5 hát tà lũ, trong đó anh dàng bị tắc độc lời nhất.
Cần thơ, đồng tháp, tây ninh cũng nằm trong vùng anh vừa.
Cô khuyến cao các địa phương hình chương ra sóa, ra cô có tính bở báo,
sự lý điểm xong yêu, chủ động tu hạt luo hệ thu đả chính,
không xung dống vụ thu đông ở vùng chưa báo đảm đu kệ trống nập.
Các tình văn biển cân sẵn sàng phương anh, tự uống, báo vệ xong xuất và dân sình.